[Musica]
ci sono le volte in cui non vorrebbe le
scatolare dei bianchi nel senso che
sapete voi però ho bisogno di compagnia
per farlo perché alle volte le cose sono
troppo oltre le mie doti da del scatola
tore quindi oggi per la puntata lin
boxing
ho chiamato un aspetti speciale lo
invita a sedersi
ciao ragazzi a me ne stai molto bene
molto bene certo parlino sentivo bene
scatolare de scatola ma come spesso
pescato la scusa quello siamo al 25
proprio da londra
non ho al portafogli non fa niente non
ti preoccupare ci riscatteremo calore
cioè con mamma america hulk mancini
sfida mona dagan crunch e credo sia la
parola crunch sa di quando morbide
fantasy quando che sia roba da mangiare
americano la speranza abbiamo vediamolo
tipo cosa dice
tutto quello che c'era e disturbi fare
va bene a me gli attrezzi del messaggio
e noi gli attrezzi del mestiere
beh se gli ha prima persona oltre mac
innescato la qual cosa sogna canale
quindi io so parlare forse bike e musica
zelda
ok ci trattiamo allora non è mai quello
che pensavo a una grande potenza i video
questo video con la gente è una roccia
come comportarmi scegliere la prima ma
non comportare danni la patria di nuovo
ma non hanno a di stop ma qualcuno dica
stop
io sono al familiare
l'arma il micro non marvel marcel
liquido è senza di me questa è senza di
semi tagli di volere di vedersi mai
stampa dire basta perché siamo tutti
veramente a più giovane di cosa che
questa è un punch hawaiano è bellissimo
il personaggio che ci sta sopra questo è
bellina pon questo è bellissima rosa e
tipo quello di fornire il limone
ho visto passare dei semini dentro marzo
con questa qua come cioè come centrata
nella scatola succo cocktail di water me
non sarebbe l'anguria dell'arizona
perché l'anguria dell'arizona ha un
sapore o poi la zona non si può
coltivare quindi è finta di zona o
perché abbiamo stanato classica parola
labani la vaniglia o magari volte lei
umani è a monte di questa fosse quella
normale avere tantissime staff ai trick
shot in questo senso è un ex allora
questo quanto disposto di mettere
solamente una molto figli vai vai
all right mosso tutto fare i muscoli
oggi ma so che sono ma vero proprio la
fantastica dottor rap o che tu sai che i
cani messi bello per te per
e l'ultima per il resto assoluto di
fornai che effettivamente novità dalla
california cosa che c'è scritto sapori
ci sono le monete al lemon disco e cioè
le monete ma l'unico sarebbero del
limone e la texture qua della opera poi
c'è un c'è solo nulla io non darei
niente di tutto questo
se invece vediamo tutto ma proprio fare
aigar facciamo insieme dobbiamo
indovinare cosa sono la parola questo
natale non male musicista giudice lui
era rimasto nascosto da ieri sera una
sorta di mario mi sto davvero bene a non
poter altro io direi che tu ci devi
interessare a tua scelta uno di questi
queste bibite bibite e dobbiamo
indovinare ci sto però magari subito il
colore siamo molto avvantaggiati es
bravo di zio cosa pensi che michela
accessorio questa allora vivendo ragazzi
21 e poi mi occupo delle miscele ragazzi
siamo pronti per giocare
vai io per pensare posso grattare la
pasta di marco
allora forse è vero anch'io aspetto
sobrio un po perché dove sono 321 nome
lo bello perché allora ci siamo sempre
tutto buono abbiamo ancora un po sempre
21 marzo era vincere ha mietuto ed un
rovescio esattamente sotto di te marco
rovescio si va lentamente
l'effervescenza di una gassosa prego
allora fattiva tre polacchi sciolti
il ruolo cavolo ma sia io lo aspetta
abbiamo due chance
la prima sonda molto in più secondo me è
quello dell'arizona marina davanti alla
gabbia ragazzi è veramente invece in più
caro che pirla prego narrativa o mio dio
cadore stranissimo il succo di punt e la
roma io invece voglio dire non meno dove
si chiamava la marca michael alla scelta
nessuno può lasciare era vestito dove
avete sbagliato abbiamo tanta qualità ma
quella di popeye arizona di spinale
loro sono carini gentili ma perché non
sanno cosa gli aspetta quindi via non
sto per dire chi perde non sarebbe
niente avere un punteggio si berrà
questo minestrone di tutti gli avanti
amico si sta facendo strada è adatto non
evere faccia sentire il prof
ammetti l'amara sessione di esempi no
però cervello quindi vi conviene aretino
più agguerriti scioglie lo stomaco bene
nex 3 1 non vincerai tutto lo prometto e
poi non sai mai che scelse compativo
come ha sì sì è vero deve reggere
toccamenti marco e il dottor pepper non
è un suv lo so e poi c'è quale è un
punto a testa da come lo è lui il primo
rimane adesso siamo noi amiamo dio ma
lei pulito bicchiere io vado a caso
proprio giusto giusto conosco quindi
perso con la gabbia
analizza dalla fine che ci aveva il
limone nella o lemonade appesa al numero
1 ve lo dico solo il reattore numero 2
che non so se mai visto veramente
pisciando addosso ma se non avesse
indovinato cosa succede alla vaniglia e
licei o mio dio questa voragine è
orribile questa roba arrivi le note
questo veramente orribile non sapere se
non due piedi per quella media di pm ma
cosa si tiene le persone con i missili
non va bene ragazzi questo qui è nullo
quindi lo verso solo attenti che lo era
così era dice no e 10 cielo e no sennò è
più è più difficile dicono cosa che cosa
ci veniva detto no è il power le
vitamine alimentarli ne ha ma mi spiace
che tool avendovi nata quando è stato
troppo tardi e panciera vogliano meli
pure sbagliato nome sbagliarmi adesso
avete l'opportunità il primo pelo
indovina e prodotti arrestato marin zone
arizona
idem i frutti delle mani fuori
all'anguria davvero
non sapeva di water meno 4 ma li sfida
ho detto coloro che dico pancia baiano
perché no io sono ancora un solo è
l'oggetto del baiano
mi sa che non dovete giocare d'anticipo
con me multimediale aspettano qualcosa
dentro questo è falso
giuro che li vita no si sceglie euro no
ce l'hai letto gr rai e non granelli
c'era una roba dentro fidati e già dei
granelli pancia voi a non so di mondo
quello rimane quello però non è sì
perché diverso affiliati pancia voi a
brozzo hammer subito ci ho messo miss
cura messa miscuglio adesso si mai messo
il miscuglio solo far accedere a linee
ea me va bene tutto
manteniamo questo è puro 22 alla
riscattati rata che questo è uscito o
mio dio sa sa di vomito lo ha vinto
marco vierin ore il dolcetti noè e abito
marco bevuto joanne o dai frater e chi
era calabria si alzi in piedi
tabellino benino baby
volevo trovare uno slogan quindi ragazzi
questa challenge è stata vinta da marco
purtroppo che va beh lasciamo perdere
questa comunque melma
ma non è un hawaiana lo un pezzo di
merda questa melma hawaiana
se va bene se cerchi la bibita e la
cerchi italiana la giusta risposta è la
melma juan va d'amore di dio adesso per
maicon e dietro di sé mio quindi per
favore del comando senza portare contano
solo a guardare
[Musica]